ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Academy Award winner Angelina Jolie the
production designers job is to design
and build everything you see on the
screen they can make you believe you're
at a racetrack in a hobbit house at an
artist studio on a British warship or
even in a samurai village in Japan the
nominees for achievement in art
direction are Ben vanassa for the art
direction and cecile Heidemann for the
set decoration of girl with a Pearl
Earring Lilly Kilvert for the art
direction and Gretchen Rao for the set
decoration of the Last Samurai grant
major in the art direction and Dan henna
and Allen Lee for the set decoration of
the Lord of the Rings The Return of the
King William Sandell for the art
direction and Robert Gould for the set
decoration of Master and Commander the
far side of the world Jeanine oka wall
for the art direction and Leslie Pope
for the set decoration of Seabiscuit
and the Oscar goes to grant major for
Lord of the Rings Return of the King for
set decoration dan dan and Alan Lee
this is the first Academy Award for
grant major Dan henna and Allan Lane who
were previously nominated last year for
the Lord of the Rings the two towers
get going well on behalf of all of us in
the art department of the Lord of the
Rings it's such a great moment to be
here and thank you very much to the
Academy it's been a long journey for us
all and it's just such an incredible
high note to finish this I finished it
on it's been an amazing ride okay I'd
like to thank newline Bob Shaye and
Michael line Michael then Michael deskey
and of course the lake color fry and I'd
like to thank the real wizard who led us
all through this amazing journey and
inspired us with his his energy his
vision and his nerve and Peter Jackson
thank you very very much for delivering
these to us and and that's all folks
yeah
you